[Music]
so one week from today
as the nation pauses for memorial day we
remember
the men and women who've given their
lives in defense of our country
well cbs's steve hartman is going to be
on the road again on the holiday for a
special reason it's going to be his
second
taps across america in fact steve's with
us live right now from his home in
upstate new york uh obviously it sounds
pretty self-explanatory but just in case
what
is taps across america
taps across america is where we're
encouraging buglers and trumpet players
across the country
to go out on their front porches and
play taps at 3 p.m
local time and we're asking people who
hear them
to play taps to go out on their front
porches
stand at attention hand over heart and
remember
where did the idea for this come from
well several years ago i did a story
about a guy named don britton who lived
in tacoma washington
and he would stand on his balcony at
sunset every day and he would play taps
and it was very moving but what struck
me most what brought me to tears
in the moment was as he played everybody
living around him
was coming out on their porches standing
in their front yards
and listening in honor and
that feeling of community that
that everybody coming together for a
single purpose really got to me for some
reason and ever since then i thought
wouldn't be great if we did this across
the country
and then when the pandemic struck last
year and all
memorial day celebrations were mostly
cancelled
i thought this is the time so how did it
go last year with those unusual
circumstances to have people all over
the country at the exact same time
doing this very special moment
it blew us away i think people wanted
this you know in our busy hectic lives
just to take a moment
and um to pause and remember
and to remember what the holiday is all
about i think so often
the meaning has become hamburgers and
hot dogs and it's not really why we have
the holiday in the first place and this
was a way for everybody
to uh be brought back to the purpose of
the holidays so for that reason
people sent us videos galore and we want
more we want we no matter where you're
standing in america at 3 p.m
you know with the highest mount in the
lowest valley we want people to hear
taps and
we want the people playing to send us
their videos and you can sign up if you
do play
at taps and you can
send us your videos and we're going to
put a lot of them on tv so is this
anybody who's ever played a trumpet or a
bugle how does that work
yeah we had a one guy who's uh he's
never
played an instrument in his life he's in
the 60s and he he got a trumpet so he
could play this year so yeah
we need a good sincere effort we really
any instrument would do
you know anything up from a kazoo we
don't want that
but um anything you can play in
reverence you know would be acceptable
yeah well steve so give us that website
one more time if folks want to learn
more about how to participate and
see how it all works sure it's
cbsnews.com
that's the easy part slash that's the
hard part because you never know if it's
slasher backslash
taps cbsnews.com taps to sign up or
learn more about it
steve right on and don't forget steve is
with us every friday night on cbs news
going on the road telling
stories about incredible people doing
incredible things all over the country
steve thanks so much we can't wait to
see how it turns out next week
thank you so much all right alex let's
send it on over to you